bien alors quand vous avez lancé un
mouvement qui s'appelle nouveau monde on
va faire une interview nouveau monde
alors jean luc mélenchon est ce que dans
le nouveau monde les enfants de 13 ans
iront en prison
non et on créera plus de place d'écoles
que place en prison ça c'est clair
est ce que dans le nouveau monde martine
aubry sera la première présidente de la
république à pourquoi pas pourquoi pas
je vous ai dit en direction des prisons
de la république au suffrage universel
indirect quoi comme ça ça a l'air sympa
en réalité sa fausse tout ça
personnalise à mort la politique c'est
plus médiatique et du quad sur cale plus
de thunes espace me lemieux la télé ça
finit comme ça hein ça finit comme ça
des fois il ya des exceptions parce que
regarder par exemple le brésil c'est le
gars de gauche qui va être un lula est
un ouvrier lula qu'il a dû s'y reprendre
à quatre fois mais alors les deux autres
fois il y avait vraiment de quoi se se
couper les mains est la télé inventé un
candidat trois mois avant et c'est comme
ça que l'on retrouvait qu'un crétin
comme color 1 1 qu'il a fallu fiche
dehors six mois après tellement ils
étaient voyous et voleur connu oui c'est
comme ça que berlusconi devenu président
en italie quoi bien non mais ce qu'ils
qualifient de votre copain copain la
nouvelle ville huilée pour l'élection du
président de la république au suffrage
universel direct
vous n'êtes pas d'accord il faut que
j'apprenne on attend on ne sert à rien
de s'en convainc serein est ce que dans
le nouveau monde
julien dray aura le droit d'entrée oui
et même de manger des cachots sans
grossir d'agen est ce que dans le
nouveau monde on aura le droit de se
pacser a3 ou a4
petit spot de publicité la première loi
déposée devant parlement première fois
qu'on a déposé une loi pour le pacs
avancer c'est moi un sénat elle était si
ce n est pas beaucoup de héros à
l'époque un bond depuis c'est devenu un
peu plus tôt +34 non je ne pense pas que
ce soit une bonne pop art c'est vrai
pourquoi mais je veux ça dépend pour
quoi faire
non mais attends je peux donner un
exemple sérieux avec de nombreux trucs
c'est pour quoi faire
mais c'est bien ce que je dis ça dépend
si c'est moi au début je voulais que
n'importe qui puisse se pacser j'étais
pas dans l'idée seulement les couples à
qui on y est tout droit en l'occurrence
les couples homosexuels
vous étiez pour le passage des frères
des soeurs de voilà on va dire ton truc
c'est une histoire de fou fait ça on va
plus s'y retrouver
il y en a qui m'ont dit tu vas favoriser
l'inceste ont donc je me suis dit le
mieux est l'ennemi du bien prenons déjà
puisque tout le monde est d'accord pour
faire le pacs on prend déjà ça et on
verra après est ce que dans le nouveau
monde la lune sera blanc de la terre
sera ronde et graphique comme dans la
chanteuse elle est super la chandelle
est ce que dans le nouveau monde y aura
toujours cette émission là oui et puis
en plus je serai plus souvent invités